so yeah then I I said the I put the hey
guys I just finished recording this
whole get ready with me video that I did
not expect it to be a get ready with me
video I was just gonna let it be a vlog
but then I ended up rambling a lot
rambling on this this Invisalign is
really hard to speak with but anyway
good morning guys
I just in my bed I just got dressed and
yes I have a lisp cuz of my Invisalign I
still haven't gotten used to it but my
teeth have shifted I've moved on to my
second tray so things are working I was
about to get ready and do my makeup I
was about to say hair but I'm actually
just right now in this very moment
decided I'm not gonna do anything to my
hair I'm just gonna leave it the way it
is but yeah it's so cool so I started
trying out this new shampoo and it
really brought out my natural curls so
like woah this shampoo is awesome I
really like it even though some mint or
it to bring up my natural curls it's
meant for moisturizing but I guess it
ended up working in this way and I also
used a first control thing so it's by
swab so I will be posting about them on
my Instagram pretty soon so you'll see
it there as well but um but yeah I am so
loving it so I'm just like you know what
I'm gonna leave my hair like this I
washed it yesterday and now that it's
the second day it looks a lot better
more tame because yesterday was like way
more poufier but it's okay I kind of dig
it and it does look messy but I like how
you can see my natural curls so yeah I'm
about to do my skincare routine and my
makeup and I know a lot of you guys have
been asking for my skincare regimen
thing
in doing so I will show it to you now
we're gonna move on to way worse
lighting well let me turn on these
things okay that's better
oh yeah look I got these vanity lights I
don't know if I ever talked about them
on my blog I think I did but I bought
them from Amazon you just stick them on
your mirror and they connect and then
you just turn it on with this little
remote thingy here so that's what I did
and it's really helpful because in this
corner of the house it's really really
dark and this is where my vanity is
something like that but these lights
really help and then sidenote look at my
cute stool I love it so much so it's an
ottoman and then if you open it you turn
it around it turns into a table I've
posted it on my story and I also posted
the link a lot of you guys were able to
get your own because it's sold out which
is so awesome but I'll still put the
link in the video description in case
you guys want to check if they've
restocked because I know these Ottomans
are very very popular and it's velvet
and it's teal and it's so pretty and it
has gold hairpin legs which I love
because it's like mid-century modern
style which I'm really diggin right now
but even if you don't want the autumn
then just click the link it helps me
just like it okay this is my skin care
regimen let you guys down alright so to
begin I wash my face which I've already
have and I get one of these cotton pad
thingies and then I use this toner so
it's by Essenza and this is a brand that
we got to visit their factory when we
were in Croatia so this is a Croatian
brand and they hooked us up with like
some tonic and then this thing that's
called like aqua lifts thermal like
royal jelly so I don't really know if
this is even a toner but I use it as a
toner because it's called gentle tonic
having is this because instead of this
aqua veg thing from them I've been using
this two one two
it's called activating serum socials of
Sarah my use okay but I'm getting ahead
of myself
first I use this and then I go like this
well I just the lipstick on flitting
realistic so first I go around
everywhere but I avoid my eyes because I
heard that tonic really dries up your
skin around your eyes cuz your eyes skin
is really sensitive so I'm just people
think so that's what I do first then I
move on to doing an eye cream by food
wetsuit that Isaac and Casey taught me
more in Korea and this is the
rejuvenating eye cream essential
rejuvenating night cream and I just
grabbed a tiny little bit cuz a little
bit of the wall right and then I go like
this like this so I was putting the
serum first and then my eye cream but
then David show showed me his phone
screen saver thingy is like the order of
how to put on your skin care stuff and
he said that you first should put your
eye cream after your your toner because
once you put the serum you don't want it
to get in your eye area I don't know I
guess the eye area is like mega mega
sensitive and I never knew this growing
up because any time I had any sort of
like scrub or any sort of cream I was
always so mindful that my dark circles
and wanting to get rid of them and I
would just like scrub the crap out of
like everywhere around my
and now I regret it because the skin
around my eyes it's like so thin and
like really really fragile and I just I
myself when I was ever because I didn't
know any better so that's the eye cream
then everyone to the serum that was
talking about and this is the stuff that
has ginseng ginseng supposed to be great
for anti-aging and I know you guys have
noticed cuz you complimented me and
thank you so much but I have seen a
crazy dramatic improvement in my skin
and the quality of my skin too and the
major thing that I've noticed is that
it's not so pale and watching like this
has helped me like by doing this regimen
it has helped me just even out the
complexion of my my skin I mean I still
have a long way to go but it's a lot
better then the next thing you do is for
the cream part of it I use this thing
this is actually a sample from Salewa so
that they gave us this one's called the
central balancing emulsion which looks
like a cream so i use it as a cream i
use it as like the moisturizer I think
that's what I mean by cream with the
moisturizer so I just tap it on the
cheek like
[Music]
you know it's crazy I do this whenever
remember I don't even do it every day
and I don't do it every morning I
usually do it at night but today or
yesterday actually I did it in the
morning and then I put my makeup on and
I noticed how my makeup stayed on so
night and like my skin was really mad
and it was just a huge difference rolls
like oh my goodness I should be doing
this in the morning
- not just at night so I've been trying
to be better about life didn't care my
skincare routine so yeah my makeup to
keep it in the school see it's useful
already love it
oh yes then before I put my makeup on I
always try to put a primer of some sort
been using this one recently that I got
as a Sephora Point gift which is glam
glow glow starter mega illuminating
moisturizer thing it's a new post I've
been using this you know this stuff I
wonder like is it okay too much cuz it's
a primary like I'm gonna put makeup on
my eyes so I do know a few months ago I
went to Sephora with Gio and I bought
this CC cream from it cosmetics but the
girl that matched me to this color like
she did it to light so I don't use it
and it's probably gonna just end up
going in the trash or maybe I'll give it
to a girlfriend but it's way too light
so I just stuck to my drugstore Revlon
Evie cream to use as my
foundation because I don't like actual
foundation and plus I want to just put
it on with my fingers I don't want to
use brushes for that stuff but I really
like it because it has SPF 30 so it's
always important to have SPF and your
makeup you know I always feel like a
caveman painting on a wall every time I
put on my foundation because I just
smear it on my don't supposed to do this
cuz I see other people like don't you
use you know like the Beauty Blender or
a brush I just use my hand then we went
to my concealer this is just how I've
always done it
it's my foundation and my concealer I
use the same concealer I've been using
for years if you ever saw the lips in my
makeup bag I'm taking a forty years and
years and years ago and then on this
channel I think I talked about my makeup
same one I have never straightaway I
have tried other concealers they just
don't do it for me this is cheap and
it's quality and it doesn't cake and it
doesn't get into all my fine lines like
other one to do it's not super shiny and
sticky like other ones I just I've been
loyal to what is this Maybelline I did
buy a silicon cat shaped the under thing
look how cute this is so I use this
sometimes when I don't want to get my
fingers even more dirty I'll just use it
so that time I'm supposed to go to a
tasting or a new restaurant concept and
our rule where we invest in restaurant
concepts and there's a tasting today so
I'm excited you get to taste some new
stuff so next what I do is my powder
foundation things I could set the greasy
stuff that I just put on my face can you
tell I know what I'm talking about
look everything boxes a retractable
brush that's really cute because this
was the original look and it's so beat
up like it's so insanely old that I've
had this brush for I feel like at least
10 years I don't even know why I
stumbled onto it maybe it's a
sentimental reason cuz I've had it for
so long but whatever I got this one now
so I use this powder to set the
foundation just make it really matte and
nice but just brush it's too big oh I'm
still trying to work with it but I have
a alarm it's
Mercia thing I hope you are enjoying
this because this ended up being illegal
makeup tutorial that I didn't expect you
know I really wish I could learn how to
contour and highlight because it looks
so good when people want or their face
and they create shadows where they don't
exist like I really wanted
my jawlines is over time like this like
like what is this my throat my Adam's
apple
oh I don't have that hole but you know
what I mean this keeps moving forward so
I'm losing losing this done so I'm gonna
do is I could contour but I think it's
coming with age and with weight gain
because now I think any more weight cuz
I'm getting like more this next I move
on to my blush I use this one that
talked about I got this at the floor
from like those mini sections by the
checkout so this is Joey Joey Joey this
is the blush that I have recently been
using so it's the brand new edition to
let me go this is like a matte finish I
top it off with this pixie blush that's
really shiny so it's like I really
haven't strayed away from how I do my
makeup since when I learned how to do
makeup when I was 16 I need to go with
the times I know but it's still working
for me so whatever then I move on to my
eyebrows so first I brush
I honestly don't even like shake them or
anything I'm just like hey this is where
I need some it cuz I know girls like
really line it like crazy and then they
put concealer and looking really nice
but I don't know how to do all that I
just do this then I use this uh Nastasia
eyebrow gel Anastasia and that's because
I have really long eyebrow hairs and
they stray away and they need a fake
foot and we want to eyelash it and man I
get a ton of PM's and comments and
questions asking what mascara I use and
honestly and I said this a lot is that I
just tried different mascaras all the
time like there's never one that I want
absolutely loyal to because to me
mascaras are all the same like for the
most part so I don't curl my eyelashes
or anything like this just how I was
born with my lashes but what I do
what happened using recently is this
Chanel mascara and this is the first
time I splurged on mascara because I got
it as a sampler from ordering some
clothes one you know I absolutely fell
in love with it like I loved that brush
but now that I bought the bigger version
they give me the same kind of brush
that's the little one had so I'm like oh
man whatever my issue with my eyelashes
is it's not length and it's not then
getting growth it's really a fullness
because I have been getting older my
eyelashes they're not as full as they
once were so that's the main thing that
I look for in mascaras is for volume
[Music]
done with my eyelashes what else that's
it that's all they do to my makeup see
these earlobes and this neck it's bare I
need to find some accessories because I
like accessorizing a lot oh I can show
you guys my jewelry thing watch for them
so this is my jewelry box and this is
also part of my jewelry and this is also
a few pieces alright so when you open
this up I have earrings I have a
bracelet in here these are all necklaces
some rings that I never use and then
just a whole bunch of airings I really
love earrings and then here's some more
stuff
I really don't accessorize that much I
tend to go to like my my favorites like
the go to pieces but everything else I
have I'm like oh one day I'll wear it
and it just never happens should I wear
gold or should I wear silver that's the
first question I ask myself and then I
look at my outfit and I'm like hmm what
should we wear I don't know if I'm
feeling gold babies either cute
I really love these I've um posted on my
stories who they're from
I can't tell you off the top of my head
right now but I usually post like if I
get them from a brand
I will definitely post who they're from
but if I buy them I'll let you know I'll
give you the link if I remember what do
you guys think I like these thank you
I also got a lot of jewelry from this
app called collectin so I got these
earrings from collectin they're so
freaking cute oh and the first ones that
I wore to these are also from collectin
yeah so it's an app that you can
download and that one for sure I'll put
the link in the description so you can
download the app and like shop my like
the jewelry jewelry pick that I like or
you could just find your own
can use my code which is real tip when
you sign up and when you sign up I get a
little bit of a kickback because it's
like hey TIFF thanks for referring this
person to our app we're gonna hook you
up a little bit so then I helps me to
that's really really helpful with you
guys use my code when you download
collect an app and then yeah once you
sign up though you can look at all the
different types kinds of jewelry so I
got this piece from there as well which
is a necklace which I think I'm gonna
wear right now I thought these earrings
from there too but I just don't know
which outfit to use and with yet these
are super cute they're like 65 and then
I also got these earrings from there
they're so cute and I have the matching
necklace it's like a necklace where you
can like wrap around you know you
together or you could just have it just
one baby and oh I did forgot to mention
to collectin is a subscription box kind
of thing so every month you can get well
they have different tiers so if you get
to a particular tier you can get an
entire box and then try out all the
jewelry you get to keep whatever you
want return whatever you don't want and
then you can post it to your tiny
boutique they call it and that's where I
got these earrings too from there we get
collected they have been wanting to this
is like some behind-the-scenes stuff but
they said that they'd be down to create
a jewelry line with me it's such a cool
opportunity is just I don't know what's
a designer like what to even go with
because there's this one girl who
created hoop rings with them like
they're really big hoop earrings cuz
she's all about hoops so it totally
matches her purple thing but for me I'm
like I don't know so that's why I've
been kind of like sitting on it cuz I
don't know what kind of jewelry I would
create but it's something that I
definitely would like to do and I'm just
I'm putting it out there in the universe
just to see like oh let's see if it
happens but I'm not promising anything
but if I would create a jewelry line
what kind of jewelry do you guys think I
should create and like I don't have any
merch so this jewelry line has been
something that I've been sitting on for
quite a while that I'm like I don't know
should I do it
some people even like it I would love to
hear your guys feedback on it alright
guys I hope you enjoyed getting ready
with me this is a unexpected get ready
with me video I would love to hear your
suggestions from when I talked about
like the jewelry line
what else do I talk about I don't know
whatever I talk too but yeah I got a hit
out now and go to a meeting and let's
see you guys next time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]